we're going yeah you know like to stand
on the bed every time she goes into a
new bedroom so that's a tradition I feel
like was a huge success to the shopping
day today right shoot just just a huge
success what's the whole nation it is
time for art what did you do you got to
do it like this this is an insult in
Britain team over yeah somebody call
somebody called me out of my chair for
doing this it's insulting in Britain so
you got to go this way but this is so
Chinese chief trainees cheese Chinese
people a big cheese which will it's not
my time side note we are getting ready
to go to our first not our first no
photographers our first 2017 disney
vacation it's our before doing this yeah
and we will film every step of the way
we are leaving tonight with the kids
there's going to be a late night place
we go get ready for that and neither is
all park yeah I'm all done I'm just
letting in my video today go check out
her channel evan has not tired at all
any need to start it is one heart one
this is a full 12 23 and we're leaving
at five baby haha x pac all right i'm
pretty much packed i have a tradition of
putting everything in one side so that's
everything all my clothes my laptop
pretty much everything we're going to
Florida it's going to be pretty light so
i don't really have to do a long heavy
stuff i usually get on the airplane with
a hoodie in long pants and I also carry
around a camera bag so I can record what
I'm doing but this enough space at the
top gear to the deals with my handbag if
I need to so I'm pretty happy with that
almost done there's one final thing you
need to do before ready to go get a
haircut because it's been too long too
long this is way too long for Florida
whether it's got to come down right no
oh yeah oh that's way better oh yeah now
I'm ready for Florida let's do it we are
in the elevator leave those fingers all
right everybody's in there fully Woody's
Nina's here I'm here hangs here we're
going yeah Lina has her Mickey she's
excited who's that guy behind their you
come there he goes do something to say
what what 15 16 seer Giancarlo look guys
let's look it's snowing outside we don't
just have hoodies we've got magic
hoodies what guys it's snowing we're
going to Florida oh yeah
oh look who we picked up let me take
that Jeffries box Stephanie's bag their
gear taller and we're all know we're
gonna get some food yeah we're going to
conclude and then get on the plane yeah
what do you want to say mr. what's your
name where we got settled in i got my
crispy chicken sandwich favorite Nina's
got pretty got here
you got a turkey bacon club definitely
what you got your rap on is the yummy
yes sir what do you got what are you
think I got a bagel six better than
normal all right definitely what do we
got PL yeah LP yes those are yummy yeah
all right good who's excited to get on
the plane ahaha you have a living get
off the plane number one is almost done
second go to sleep and the Bliss yes
great Liz all right maybe not just some
ninja baggage putting up like banking
policies necklace here and then we've
got the two boys on the other side I
they're going to have a great sleep on
the place very
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
alright this past midnight he arrived we
got the late because of the snow in
Toronto we're here me just a little bit
Haven plus what he's kind of floating
out there is stunning edge we're going
to get our rental car and find our play
it is turning this yep get you pretty
tired yep we're going to go get our car
rental we're going to go side floor but
it's not it's not crazy hot where's the
snow guys all i see is palm trees yeah
and the nice warm was air yeah in smoke
well you know he gets out of your [ __ ]
ok so it's 140 140 am we couldn't figure
out how to turn our data on and then we
got lost and then we stopped at
walgreens to get some cereal for
tomorrow until the gritty to them hungry
we are tired kids are getting ready for
bed this is nina i'm here where I think
the next place well little hope we'll
look you guys in on what's happening
tomorrow we're going to get ready for
bed rest up photoshopping day first week
citing we need someone we're locked out
of our bedrooms misusing
oh there you go how's the red room like
will show you the bedroom I mean I like
to stand on the bed every time she goes
into a new bedroom so that's what
tradition don't fall have a great night
guys okay in the morning all right happy
day one day one day one England what we
are you know I went to sleep okay take
it for four and those a check time
change as well and it is your hands man
it's all been taken yet your hat is a
weapon catch electrons we're eating
breakfast we're in our Airbnb and then
I'm going to get ready to go out do some
shopping ha maybe just a Pokemon jump
all right we're outside it is hot and we
like it we're looking for geckos oh yeah
did nobody move there it is so today's
shopping day we will get Nina some stuff
we do you think Nina what are you hoping
to find hmmm nothing well if you're
hoping if I nothing I think you're in
luck as they go find nothing the kids
are in the bag of what are you guys
doing this meeting how to thank you go
oh hey turn the traction I love it good
job let's go we found the cell physician
[Music]
look you some body wave Xena all right
we made our first stop malls at
millennium it is very excited Jeffrey's
just punch me in the face on that jump
Jeffrey Nina the discipline that's like
life sometimes punches you in the face
and you keep going that's how we roll
[Music]
first stop of the day starbucks right
happy star barking
okay let's see it mr. oh good job mr.
we're hearing Microsoft again maybe this
first time with your charm i'm going to
try again let's see it's seen its turn
yay third time is the third time here
which one archery or the join or the
whales you want to see it okay name is
excited
[Music]
good eating out good either go you know
they're gonna kill you oh wow what
happened there the piece that has
arrived open it up even doesn't want any
anymore
ah
paying a lot all of the cheese okay sent
me the jeebies with no cheese
[Music]
what yeah you know my question
alright well we have two whole pizzas
easy who says here we go
[Music]
Oh
all right we're done we're leaving one
mall Nina fought all right just thanks
to the same thing cheating by we spent
half the time I think it's a microsoft
store absolutely this we're all alpha
where we very full we eat two
extra-large pizzas between the five of
us three kids then Nina he had the
biggest slice at the end no is pretty
epic 50 did she has a bigger slice this
matter you know my wingman don't spit on
yourself okay we're going to get in the
car and go to another this is a regular
ball we're going to go to an outlet mall
now for Nina include outlet mall it's a
mall with lots of outlets here we go
[Music]
here comes ready guys my name's
blurryface and I care what you think
mine is Larry things i do what you think
all right all right all right we made it
awesome chaos in the parking lot we are
going to the premium outlet mall the
Vineland cream outlet mall where Nina is
going to buy something what are we
hoping to find Nina oh I don't know
shoes a toy for hating I thank thank ya
know Jeffrey toy now ya know it's me
today we're here to find something for
Nina because we loved her she's special
and she deals with all of us what all
right you gotta love Nina like you like
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]
we're heading back limited by anything
out hey that was it just just the
Sephora what did you buy against uh oh
the eyeliner liner primer on primer I
kind of feel like that was like an
insane eyeliner do you like that was
maybe worth the whole trip that comes to
Florida hang by the eyeliner Mike I feel
like was a huge success the shopping day
today right she just just a huge success
like if that's all we got for the whole
week it was a big win ok back to the car
get some goes to shopping done and then
go home yeah it's time to do everybody's
favorite part of the whole chick goes to
shopping
[Applause]
but food
[Music]
nemeth just a lot of food for one week
to pop it on hahaha chocolate if I
wouldn't buy one Nina get one free
Lena's one-of-a-kind okay doesn't exist
wow that's a lot of that's a lot of food
for one week Nina it's not a lot of food
just the bare essentials you know some
stella some wine it's just a package it
it's a lot of stuff no it's not a lot of
stuff in a it's a big package with
nothing inside do you think do the
opposite you're a lot of stuff in a
little package okay we love you we made
it home
oh yeah time to pack up the food inside
and eat some dinner I got dinner right
in my hand that's tomorrow mr. we're not
having cereal for doing I mean I might
have some later not for the kid all
right Nina's cooking us and give me food
what do we have Nina oh yeah some yummy
potatoes look at that I'm peanut green
beans nice Hey oh yeah look at that
takes trip what inspired this Nina know
you're hungry for steak what's your code
like all right dinnertime so that's the
so that's the end of day one realized i
forgot to make a video we want we we had
an awesome dinner and then just put the
kids to bed and chill in the couch watch
some shark tank add some beer yeah time
to catch up with some sleep because we
didn't sleep that well yesterday wake up
and go to the baseball game whoo DOJ's
go thank you guys for joining us for day
one let's hope for an amazing d 2 and a
blue jays victory good night